[Music]
jennifer's in minneapolis hi jennifer
how are you
hi dave it's an honor to speak with you
today you too how can i help
we have a question about baby step 3b
because we want to move
significantly up in house a question is
in this market we understand contingent
offers are generally not
accepted so we have been advised to
consider a bridge loan
what would you say i would say the idiot
that advised you that should agree to
pay the payments
okay um here's here's the problem
stuff like that doesn't work unless
everything goes perfect and everything
never goes perfect
okay okay let's just pretend that
something like a pandemic happened
okay i don't know i mean i never never
experienced anything like that
uh but let's say you were right in the
middle of this and you had one foot on
the boat and one on the dock and the
boat was leaving
you know where you're going to end up
and that's in the lake
uh-huh meaning you're going to end up
with a bridge loan payment
a house payment and another house
payment
okay can i get your numbers in our
scenario and you can tell me kind of
what you what
i would do is sell your house and go
rent something while you buy if a
contingency won't work
okay and that's what i that's what i
personally have
done by the way because see i'm more i'm
worse off than you
because i don't borrow money at all sure
and so i if i have to have the money out
of the house to buy the next house
i can't buy it
until i get the other one closed and so
that
that entails a double move or a
contingency offer
okay and so that's the only way around
it because and i've done that i've i
mean sharon and i have done that
not a whole bunch of times and it's not
ideal it's not my favorite
but uh and if you can get a really good
solid offer on your house it's a cash
offer
you know because the market's so hot
people are waving they're waving
appraisals they're waving everything and
they're just making offers right
waving inspections they're doing
everything and you get a good solid cash
offer on your house then you can make a
really good solid contingency offer
and talk them into just waiting until
yours closes right quick because they
ought to be able to close them both
within a week or two
and just run them back-to-back dominoes
it can be done but
it's uh it's very it is very hard it is
very hard
and it's harder it's more work for your
poor little realtor bless their little
heart
and so they're gonna get two commissions
the sale of yours and purchase on the
other side and so they're just gonna
have to do their little work
uh instead of you getting a bridge loan
and getting caught in the middle
please don't do that everything that can
go wrong will you gonna meet mr murphy